foreign
we say these words
every time
when
we respond
to our national motto
glory to Ukraine we're here and we're
here about those
thanks to whom our country lives
these how the history of our country
sounds and the years of our fight for
our independence that's how we honor our
generations of those
who strongly
was fighting to defend cave and
everywhere in free Ukraine
so that our
blue and yellow flag
s across Ukraine and that's how we honor
the generation that is now fighting for
Ukraine
we
honor everybody
who became a fighter for Ukraine
for our country
we remember everyone
who was saving ukrainians we remember
everybody
who lost their lives
so that Ukraine could live
all moments of our great
path that our people went through
in this respect in this honor in these
words
of respect and tributes
that reflect
feelings of everyone millions of people
and we know that it will be in this way
because
Our Heroes saved
this for us I want to address everybody
now
who chose this destiny
to all our heroes I'm talking
[Music]
to those who are present here in Sofia
Square who can hear me right now
in all different parts of the world
those who are fighting right now for
Ukraine for Ukraine today
and who is bringing our Victory closer
I'm speaking to those
who already heard about gratitude of
ukrainians
to those who
helps all of us our country
everybody who helps Ukraine to overcome
these challenges and difficulties and
those whose bravery Honesty will become
the basis the ground for existence of
our country I'm speaking to you now
Ukrainian Soldier
I'm talking to you
save of ukrainians
I'm speaking to you
helper of the country
today
after the year of an important War for
the independence of Ukraine
in this important place that euroslav
and Bogdan and Mahalo saw and others who
used to fight for Ukraine I want to tell
everybody who is fighting for Ukraine
today and who lives with Ukraine in
their hearts I want to say that I'm
proud of you all of us
everybody
all of us we are all proud of you
and let this
feeling of being proud go through our
streets squares
and through the hearts and countries
and let it be heard in every country let
Ukraine live
and let this feeling of being proud this
feeling of dignity
show how many Heroes lost their lives
for Ukraine
for our country our people